THERE'S A DISTINCTION.
>> NO GROUP IS PERFECT.
THAT IS AN UNDERSTATEMENT.
IS IT TIME TO CLASSIFY ANTIFA AS
A TERROR GROUP?
BERNIE IS HERE HELPING TO PUT
TOGETHER AN ANTI TERROR TASK
FORCE.
COMMISSIONER, HOW DO YOU LABEL
THIS GROUP?
>> FIRST OF ALL, THIS IS AN
EXTREMELY VIOLENT GROUP THAT
GOES OUT AND THREATENS,
INTIMIDATES, ATTACKS WITH
EXTREME VIOLENCE FOR POLITICAL
REASONS.
IF YOU LOOK UP TERRORISM, THE
DEFINITION OF TERRORISM, THAT'S
WHAT TERRORISM IS.
WHEN SOMEBODY THREATS, IMPOSES
THREATS AND VIOLENCE FOR
POLITICAL REASONS.
I THINK, I SAID THIS IN THE PAST
AND SOME PEOPLE WOULD DISAGREE,
I THINK THEY SHOULD BE
DESIGNATED AS A DOMESTIC TERROR
GROUP LIKE THE BLACK LIBERATION
PARTY AND THE BLACK PANTHER
PARTY AND THE JACKSON UNIT BACK
IN THE 70s AND 80s, 60s.
JUST LIKE THEY WERE.
AND I THINK THAT'S HOW YOU'LL
HAVE TO DEAL WITH THEM BECAUSE
THE LOCALS, THE LOCAL STATE,
POLICE ENTITIES NOW ARE NOT
DOING THAT.
I WATCH THIS DEMONSTRATION IN
PORTLAND.
I WAS APPALLED THAT THE POLICE
WASN'T MORE ACTIVE, PREEMPTIVE,
PROACTIVE.
SOME OF THE BEAT DOWNS THIS
YOUNG JOURNALIST WAS BEATEN,
SEVERELY BEATEN, NOT JUST
SMACKED AROUND, SEVERELY BEATEN
WITH SUBSTANTIAL INJURIES.
THIS STUFF IS GROWING.
IT'S IN PORTLAND, CALIFORNIA,
IT'S IN -- A LOT OF THESE STATES
WHERE YOU HAVE DEMOCRATIC
LEADERSHIP AND DEMOCRATIC
MAYORS.
>> Brian: THEY STARTED IN THE
70s, ANTI-FASCISTS.
THEY WANT TO PUSH BACK.
NOW THEY'RE ANTI-TRUMP AND
ANTI-CONSERVATIVE.
THAT WAS A JOURNALISTS.
I THOUGHT WE WERE WORRIED ABOUT
JOURNALISTS.
WHAT ABOUT THE FISTS?
>> IT'S ONLY ANTI-JOURNALISTS
WHEN IT'S -- THAT'S OKAY WHEN
THEY'RE CONSERVATIVE.
IF THEY'RE CONSERVATIVES, NO
HOLDS ARE BARRED.
THEY GET TO DO WHAT THEY WANT.
I THINK IT'S GOT TO STOP.
I THINK THESE POLICE
DEPARTMENTS, THEY KNOW WHEN
THEY'RE COMING OUT.
THEY KNOW WHEN THE
DEMONSTRATIONS WILL BE.
THEY HAVE A BASIC IDEA OF HOW
MANY PEOPLE WILL BE THERE.
UNDER RUDY GULIANI WHEN I WAS
POLICE COMMISSIONER, THIS WOULD
BE ALL HANDS ON DECK TO MAKE
SURE THIS DIDN'T HAPPEN.
>> Brian: AND YOUR POLICE FORCE
WOULD HAVE KNOWN HOW TO STOP IT.
NOW MAYORS UNDER FIRE.
FINAL THOUGHT ON THIS,
COMMISSIONER.
YOU KNOW, YOU'RE WORRIED ABOUT
THESE GUYS ASSEMBLING.
SOCIAL MEDIA HAS TO CLAMP DOWN.
WHAT ARE THEY WAITING FOR?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
THEY KNOCK PEOPLE OFF THE AIR,
THE CONSERVE
THE CONSERATIVES JUST FOR A
COMMENT.
I WATCH THESE BEATDOWNS, DOZENS
OF VIDEOS ON ANTI-CONSERVATIVE
SITES THE LAST FOUR OR FIVE
DAYS.
JUST OUTRAGEOUS.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO.
>> Brian: YOU HAVE TO STAND UP
FOR YOURSELF AND I'M GLAD THIS